FEMALE SPEAKER: So
welcome everybody.
Welcome to a conversation I'm
going to have with a woman
I admire very much.
Ellen Gustafson.
And she has just
released "We the Eaters."
She is quite a powerful woman.
And she's put
together two things--
food and writing-- which
are usually very quiet,
small things in this small book
with a very powerful message.
And it's pretty revolutionary.
So I want to welcome
you to Google.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And
thank you for coming.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON:
Thanks for having me.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So why
should we be eating.
And even more
important than that,
why should we be
eating dinner-- which
is one of your main points.
And dinner just
sounds so traditional.
We sit down to dinner.
Grandma, mom, makes
a roast chicken.
But why is eating
dinner together now
such a revolutionary act?
You've put it on
these pages for us.
Can you tell us?
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: It's
interesting to kind
of frame food in a lot of the
different areas of our lives
and of global issues that
sometimes food doesn't
get kind of plugged into.
Obviously we know that food
is incredibly connected
to our health, and our
personal health, and maybe even
community health.
But sometimes we miss a
lot of the other elements
that food brings us to.
And in this book I talk
a lot about politics--
big, global politics issues.
But also even relationships
at a much more personal level.
And so dinner is such
an iconic example
of when the family-- the
very small body politic--
gets together and talks.
And the family life
is really borne
from that experience of spending
time together, and talking
and learning, and learning
about family history,
and learning about
the food itself.
And it's really something
that many of us have lost.
And I think that that can
then be sort of extrapolated
to a lot of other
big picture issues.
Where if this meal is something
that we think of as just a
throwaway, cheap, pick
up on the way home,
drive-through-- well
think about what
that's done to
culture in general,
and then to a lot of these
other big global issues.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I think the
very radical act of sitting down
with people you live with or
care about is so compelling now
in the days when people stand
by their kitchen sink and eat.
Or as you say, drive by.
Or don't even eat.
Maybe it's just a snack.
Maybe it's a piece
of something that you
can put boiling water on and be
through eating in five minutes.
What brought you to this?
Why did you put it at
the center of your life?
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: Well
I didn't actually
start working on
food issues as all.
I'm myself an eater.
I love to eat.
And I think as a
woman-- especially
as a young woman--
eating actually
posed a lot of
challenges for me.
I mean, even just
fitting into your jeans
is challenging in our
modern culture of food.
And so that was always
something in the back of my head
just as a young person
growing up in America,
and being frustrated that
you hit a point where
everyone notices.
OK, I guess you're
going to be at the age
now where you're going
to start gaining weight.
And that seems like
a foregone conclusion
in our modern society.
Which is silly.
It shouldn't be the case.
But actually my work--
my professional life
and my focus-- was much
more on big global issues
like terrorism and
security issues.
And when I was in a senior
at college in New York City,
9/11 happened.
I was very, very focused
on understanding terrorism
and why these things
happen in the world,
and what's gone on in
our modern society that
led to this really radical
shift in people's beliefs
about Americans and
about Western culture.
And actually those
two things together
brought me to my current work.
And it seems kind of crazy,
but in one of my jobs
working on terrorism issues
as an investigative reporter,
I was looking at the global
map of terrorism and places
where terrorist
groups are operating.
And I also randomly saw this map
from the World Food Program--
the hunger map.
And I noticed that, my God,
they're incredibly similar.
Places around the world
where people are hungry
are always connected to
places around the world
where people are violent,
and uprisings occur,
and terrorism then eventually
festers and happens.
And that to me was such
an unbelievable link
and connection, and
it led me to switch
from working on terrorism to
working on fundamental food
security and hunger,
and kind of move along
in my career in a
totally different way.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So
interesting to me
that you went from
the sexier topic
of-- if you will-- terrorism.
If it bleeds, it leads.
Kind of investigative reportage
that brought you to this way
quieter, less sexy subject,
but so fundamental.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: Absolutely.
FEMALE SPEAKER: To
culture, society, politics.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: Yeah.
I mean, people miss that.
We think of the after-effects.
How are we going to
fight these people?
How are we going
to fight terrorism?
And not maybe the
fundamental issues
of how are we going to prevent?
It's actually the same thing we
look at when we look at health.
Instead of thinking of how
we're going to prevent disease,
we think of how we're
going to fight disease.
And it's this whole look at
fighting the problem after it
happens, instead of
preventing these issues
from ever happening again.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So all
the downstream things that
are so much more easy
to talk about then
the fundamental things.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: Right exactly.
Exactly.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So OK.
9/11.
Tell us a little of the
personal journey that
brought you to
what you do today.
Because you have
done so many things.
You're called an activist.
But you're really
a person who cares
so much about
fundamental values.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: So yeah.
I didn't really
start as an activist.
I shifted over from my
work as a journalist
to the UN World
Food Program itself,
working in the organization.
It's the largest humanitarian
organization in the world.
And I started my job there as
a public information officer,
as a spokesperson.
And so one of my jobs
was talking to the media
and getting to
understand hunger,
and why they should
care about hunger.
And of course I always
brought in this angle
that we should care about hunger
because we care about terrorism
and the downstream effects.
But also we were
looking for ways
to get young people
engaged in hunger.
Actually, when I started
working there in 2006,
although food security now
is maybe a little bit sexier,
it really wasn't at all then.
And I met one of the
celebrity ambassadors
that was representing the
UN World Food Program.
And she and I kind of
developed this idea
to start a company that sold
products-- the products were
called feed bag-- and each
feed bag sold would give money
back to the UN World Food
Program to raise money
and to raise awareness
about the problem of hunger,
and let people have a
tangible way to give.
It's funny.
We started this company in
a complete vacuum really.
In New York, but
not really knowing
there was a whole movement.
And Tom's Shoes-- this
other iconic accessories
brand about giving
back-- was starting
at the exact same time.
So there was almost
this zeitgeist
happening around this whole
social entrepreneurship
movement, and caring
about global issues,
but through your
consumer dollars.
And so starting Feed was
a huge, huge thing for me.
It was an incredible experience
running a business, a fashion
business, but also
getting people
to care through their
consumer purchases
about this issue of hunger.
But eventually as my years
working on global hunger
continued, I had this aha
moment that I talk about
in the book where I
was in Uganda working
on hunger issues,
as you might expect.
And I went into a
store to get food
to take with me out to a
day's work in the field--
while visiting projects
that we were funding,
and visiting different things
that aid organizations were
working on.
And going into a little store
in this small city in Uganda.
I mean, really not Kumpala.
Not [INAUDIBLE].
Not one of the main cities.
And it was literally
packed with junk.
And I remember driving
through these dirt roads.
There's soda.
Pringles are everywhere.
I don't know how
they get everywhere.
There's ice cream
in so many places
that have barely safe water.
And chips and packaged
sweets and pastries.
And I was like how have we
got somehow, this system where
we can get people
Coca-Cola literally
in 200 countries, more countries
than are recognized by the UN,
and somehow we can't get
healthy basic food that's
grown locally.
And it really struck me when
I flew back to the States
and went into one of those
Hudson new stores, that
are in every airport, and
it's literally all junk.
It's the same stuff.
And I had this aha moment
of like, wait a minute.
This is much more similar
than it is different.
Our problems at home of obesity
and fitting into our jeans,
and everybody gaining weight,
and all the health problems
related to that.
And this hunger
problem that I've
been working that
seemed so far away,
are so much more similar
than they are different.
And then I started working on
the connection between the two.
And eventually this book.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Beautiful.
So it's malnutrition.
It's eating bad food.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: Exactly.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Food that
causes disease, and doesn't
maintain and sustain you.
What a journey.
And Feed-- did I read
that you fed 6 million?
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: Well yes.
So actually, the
numbers today of Feed--
which has continued and
been really successful
over the years since we
started in 2007-- they've
provided 80 million school
meals to kids around the world.
And while I was there,
it was 60 million.
So the numbers keep going.
And what's interesting too,
the timing of my own journey
is while I was at Feed--
started in 2006-- in 2008,
there was this
global food crisis
and hunger was skyrocketing.
And so we were at our best year.
We are providing so many
millions of school meals.
But the problem of hunger
was growing so dramatically.
And it really made
me think that there's
something so much bigger here.
The system is
really the problem.
This is not something that we
can just only throw money at.
We have to figure
out fundamentally
how to change this system.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And how
should we change the system?
Where should each
one of us begin?
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: Well
it comes eventually
through thinking,
and researching,
and writing this book.
But also just really
deeply looking
at how the interconnection
between our food system at home
and these food systems I've
seen overseas is-- Americans
decide what the world eats.
And the more you travel,
the more you see it.
In countries and cultures
that people have always
eaten incredible traditional
diets, and diverse crops
from their own regions and
soils, now more and more,
it's what we eat.
And its our varieties, and
it's our agricultural systems,
and it made me
think that Americans
have a huge responsibility.
Hence "We the Eaters."
We have a huge
responsibility to understand
that our eating
habits themselves
have a massive impact
around the world.
And if we don't get them
right-- if we export the junk
food and the fast
food and the soda,
as we have been
doing-- that is what
the world is going to look like.
They're going to look just like
us as they're starting to do.
And so if we get it
right here at home,
if we figure out how
to make a system work,
like we figured out how to
get cell phones to be really
successful, and now there's
more African cellphone consumers
than there are North American
cell phone consumers.
We can do that
with food systems.
We just haven't
figured out yet how.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I think
China and India are
vying for diabetes
capital of the world.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: Yeah.
Mexico.
I mean, all these countries.
And it's not because their
own people are somehow
changed and lazy, like
the messaging we hear.
And their personal
responsibility
has gone down the toilet.
No it's because
they're eating more
and more of the Western diet.
FEMALE SPEAKER: It's
the fast food diet.
And it fits in such a
weird way and so quickly
into their cultures.
I think what it took
America since the '50s
in the last century to do,
it's taken them 10, 20 years
to get to this place of
disease and non-health.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: Well
and the flip side
of that is that we built this
system-- the fast food system,
the soda system, the junk
food proliferation system.
And it works really well.
And we've perfected it.
And now it works really well.
And so there is
absolutely no reason
we can't do that
with healthy foods.
It's not like a
foregone conclusion
that this is the
only food that we
can make in a way that's
produced and available.
The systems have
to be different,
but we can-- and actually
here we are in the Bay Area,
and we can see that the
alternative can work.
In almost every small
place you go into now
in the San Francisco
Bay Area has
some semblance of
local purchasing,
or healthier food, or
green juice, or kale.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And
more kale and more kale.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: And
And so the fact is, we can
make these systems work
for healthier foods.
It's just a matter
of the entrepreneurs
and the eaters joining forces
to make the better system work.
FEMALE SPEAKER: It is going to
look different though, right?
You envision a future where we
sit down to dinner together.
It may be in a traditional
nuclear family.
It may be me and a friend on
a webcam across the country.
Or what would it look like?
Tell us.
Give us an idea of what you see.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON:
Well it's funny.
I mean, we've obviously
kept eating dinner.
That hasn't gone away.
What we've eaten has
changed so dramatically.
And so I think sometimes
I'm always kind of amused--
I guess that's the only way to
describe it-- when people talk
about how incredibly
busy they are,
and how they have
to stay at work,
and that's why they
can't cook dinner.
And these are not people
that have their finger
on the big red button.
I mean, we're just people
who are working our jobs.
That's a culture shift that
we can take some control of,
and say no, it's actually
important to go home and eat
dinner with people, and
sit, and take the time.
So I think that's something
that we have to really invest
time and energy into
as a culture shift.
And it's totally possible.
But the flip side
is we have to find
ways to make healthier food
options more available,
and I hate to say
it, but easier.
You know, it's ridiculous
that the easiest thing is
this wildly subsidized, actually
incredibly expensive hamburger
meal is somehow the
cheapest, easiest thing.
And we have got to
find ways, and we
have to find the
entrepreneurs, and we
have to find the systems, and
the farmers, and the politics,
and the policies that
work to make the easier
thing, and the cheaper thing
the healthier thing like it
always should have been.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And so you're
saying, have a hamburger.
Have it maybe not so often.
Go buy your grass-fed beef.
Buy a beautiful artisan-made
bread, maybe whole wheat.
And nothing wrong
with a hamburger,
but make it from scratch.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: Yeah.
I try-- I mean myself,
I love burgers.
So I'm certainly never
going to tell anyone
to eat a certain diet.
And I'm not a
nutritionist nor a doctor.
That's not my role, I think.
But I think we've gotten so far
off-kilter that the only way
to be healthy is
to eschew foods.
But the reason
that we think that
is because the foods are
actually not really the foods.
I mean, the burger
that you think
of that you might get at
the fast food restaurant
is certainly terrible for you.
But it's not because red
meat itself is the devil,
or we shouldn't be eating
these entire food groups.
I think what we've done
to the food group-- what
the modern version
of the food group
is, is certainly like
a bastardized version.
But it's not the food itself.
And that's something I
think we're wrestling with.
And I think as young
people-- there's
a generation of my
friends, my generation
is starting to really
think differently.
Do we want to spend
the rest of our lives
on a highly restrictive diet?
Or do we want to really
think about where
our food comes from?
And maybe that is
the restrictive diet
that helps us both maintain
our health goals and our weight
goals, but also
happens to be better
for the whole world and
the environment too.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And I think
it is starting to happen.
With some of the research
that's coming out.
So I have one more question
before I open the conversation
up to everybody in the room,
which is you were a journalist.
And so what made
you say I'm going
to stop investigating
and reporting about it.
I'm actually going to
do something about it.
That's a very courageous
switch to make.
What happened in
here, or in here?
ELLEN GUSTAFSON:
Well I think first
of all, just incredible
frustration and maybe more
than a journalist--
at my core, I'm
more of an entrepreneur, because
I love when people say no,
and that just means I have
to find a way around it.
But I think it's so frustrating
to read about especially
health in our
country, and to read
about the environment
in our country,
and to read about global
hunger-- children starving
in a world of well enough
calories for everybody
to survive and thrive.
And just to see that, and
read that, and report on it
was really personally
very frustrating.
And then to work on the flip
side at a major organization--
the World Food Program--
which does so much good work,
but to even see in
that organization
how our American food
system has in some ways
even bastardized food aid.
We're giving a lot of
corn and soy excess
that American farmers
are growing probably
too much of,
sending it overseas,
and then embedding those
systems of corn-based food
systems in countries around the
world where people are needy,
where they should be growing
their own local foods that
probably are healthier.
And so all of this together.
Seeing this so clearly, I just
couldn't stand aside anymore
and watch it without
trying to find
ways to fix it and change it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Wonderful story.
And I think the
book will tell more,
but you've done many other
activities-- entrepreneurial
as well as policy stuff--
that's really exciting.
Thank you so much for
doing what you do.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
I'm going to let everybody
else join in the conversation.
If you have a question, Ellen
is happy to answer them.
AUDIENCE: What would you tell
to a Coca-Cola exec or a Pepsi
exec?
And it's funny,
because Pepsi just
released their "a
real sugar drink."
Which is funny that they
put that label on the bottle
to begin with.
But what would you
tell them to make
their case, via you're making
millions, billions of dollars,
but we want you to
do this instead.
What's the case for
them saying, "I agree?"
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: Well
what's interesting is
that I feel-- especially
coming into this
and this book being
released in 2014--
is I almost don't have
to tell them anything,
because the marketplace is
telling them everything.
You know, the young
women, myself included,
who in college used
to drink Diet Coke,
thinking that was
the healthier option.
Our wildly moving
away from drinks
like that because of the
artificial ingredients.
And I don't see where the future
is for those products when
the hard-core consumer
of those products
is now completely leaving.
They're not coming back.
It's not like all
of a sudden I'm
going to have to
start feeding Diet
Coke to my children
in the future.
So I think that the consumer
has spoken in many ways.
And so what's been interesting
to watch is a couple things.
Coca-Cola specifically is
investing a lot more in water.
They're investing
a ton in juice.
They're investing in-- even
in juice facilities overseas,
they've done some interesting
projects in Africa,
building mango juice
processing facilities
for African consumers.
Because the messages are
trickling around the world
so much faster,
because of obviously
tools like Google
and the internet,
but people are
learning about health
not just here as Western
consumers, but everywhere.
So people are drinking
less soda because they're
realizing the impacts of it.
So I think that that's
really interesting.
That Coke is hearing that
message without major activists
or whatever speaking about it.
But what's also
interesting though,
is that it's a system
that they live in.
So one of the things-- they're
this really interesting
nonprofit in Africa, I
think it's called Cola Life.
But what they use is the
same facilities and logistics
and infrastructure
that brings soda
to literally every
corner of the planet,
is now being used to
bring medicine and just
basic needs for communities.
And what's interesting
is, that's great.
And that is using the
system for better, right?
Bringing medicine to
people who need it.
But isn't it really the system
that we have to think about?
Should we have a
centralized American company
based in Atlanta providing
beverages for the entire world?
I don't know.
What's funny about food
is it's not a widget.
It's not a cellphone.
It's great that you can
make widgets and cellphones
in one factory, centralized
probably in Asia, highly
replicable and mechanized.
That, unfortunately,
is not what food is.
And I don't think that
most eaters want food
to go that way.
So I think what we have
to really investigate
is can Coca-Cola be successful
in a decentralized way?
Can they really just
be a holding company
for a lot of local companies
that do their own business
and their own production
around the world?
Is there a way for them to
succeed in an environment
where people don't want
super-centralized food systems,
and they want local, and
healthier, and more fresh food.
And I think that's
their challenge.
And I think they're
listening to it.
And they're trying
to figure that out.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Maybe fortunately
rather than unfortunately
that food is so local.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: Yeah.
No one else can sleep for you.
No one else can
exercise for you.
I don't know why we've
become conditioned
to think that somebody
else can eat for you,
or can cook every
single thing you're
going to put in your mouth.
And people laugh, it's so funny.
I always think about this
image, but you know that machine
where you stood there, and
like the band would shake you
back and forth?
OK.
Everyone laughs at
that, but that's
exactly what we do with food.
We think we can just stand there
and have somebody else give it
to us.
And we know how ridiculous it is
that that machine can exercise
for us, but we don't see how
ridiculous the same thing is
that we just stand
there with a conveyor
belt of food coming
into our mouths.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Great image.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON:
But it really is
something we have
to think about.
Although I want one of those
machines, because it looks
like a lot of fun.
AUDIENCE: Thanks, Ellen.
I'm skipping to the
last part of your book,
because I think
anyone that is trying
to make a change-- whether
they're improving their food
literacy skills-- or just trying
to make a change in general,
you offer 30 points here.
And I guess the question
is, for you specifically,
what were some of the ones that
you grasped early on to make
a change, and what would be some
of the ones that ;you brought
to the audience as simple
things as early wins?
Because trying to make
a complete change in how
you deal with food, see food,
consume food is daunting.
Especially with what
we've been eating.
So for someone who's
trying to make a change,
where would some of the tips
be to say, hey start with this.
And try this.
And then go to the next one.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: That's
a great question.
What's interesting
is I think people
come at food for
mostly health reasons.
And so I think
those tend to be--
the health-related
changes-- tend
to be the easiest for
people to understand.
Cutting back the sugar.
Just reading labels
and noticing,
if sugar or a form of sugar
is the first ingredient,
this is probably not a
great food to be eating.
Cutting out
high-fructose corn syrup
is something that-- especially
my generation of young moms--
is just wildly shifting
their purchasing habits.
Looking for that
product and just
saying I'm not buying something
with that product in it
is a really interesting change.
Shifting to healthier
raised meats
is something that a lot
of young, aware consumers
are doing.
And then paying attention
to vegetables and fruits
and saying, can I get something
that's more in season.
Can I get something
that's organic?
that's local?
That's all so much easier now.
The proliferation of
farmers' markets, and CSAs,
and ways to buy directly
from local farms
is really a radical shift in
like the last 10 to 15 years.
And so that's easy.
And I say that sitting
in San Francisco,
but I really want
to stress that I
do a lot of speaking
on college campuses,
and I was at the University
of South Dakota in April.
And I witnessed the
most incredible array
of student food projects.
They actually made
different foods,
which is like the
greatest job ever,
I got to taste all
the stuff they made.
But raw whole milk
from a local dairy.
Stuff from the
farmer's market that's
twice a week in
Vermillion, South Dakota.
I went to Eastern Kentucky
University on a day
that they had a farmer's
market, and they offered me
a vegan option in the cafeteria.
So this is not stuff
that's just happening
in our bubble of the Bay Area.
It's actually really happening
all across the country, which
is amazing and really
important I think.
So I think those health-related
food changes are a great start.
But I also included some
steps-- one of them,
just to highlight
it, I think is so
interesting-- is to try
to walk to your meal.
And it's something--
young people
want walkable environments.
We go to college, we
can walk to everything.
And then all of a sudden you
go out to the rest of universe,
unless you live in a
major city, you literally
can't walk to get anything.
But I think that idea of livable
communities where you can just
walk to buy a food
item is something
that helps to shift
our societies.
And so that is like a
non-food related change,
but something that I
think a lot of people
would become aware of.
And say, "Wow.
Can I walk to get
a piece of food?
Maybe not.
And maybe is that
something I would
like to investigate
and try to figure out."
And then the other thing
is, of course, a big thing.
But getting people
to just try to cook.
I always was frustrated a couple
years ago during the Occupy
Movement.
And this became one of
the points in my book,
is if you want to really be a
radical, occupy your kitchen.
Don't sit there sleeping out
on the tent, where you clearly
can't cook for yourself, and
you would see the images where
there's like the big thing of
Coca-Cola and Heinz ketchup.
And I'm like, are you serious?
You're trying to rail
against large companies,
but you're literally
ingesting the large companies.
Like talk about taking
it from the man.
You're eating the man right now.
And so I always think, if
you want to be a radical,
if you want to
really be the change,
the first thing
you can do is cook.
And it doesn't matter
what you make, even.
You're just kind
of saying, screw
the man by getting
in the kitchen.
And so I think whether you come
at it from that kind of more
political side, or you come
at it from the health side,
there's so many
things that do add up
to major changes in
our food economy.
AUDIENCE: Maybe even a
step before that too,
is before even knowing your
kitchen, knowing your food.
Planting some things too.
So there's a lot of people
out there who are farming.
You look all around
the Google campus,
and there are garden everywhere.
But would you say that more and
more people are getting back
into understanding a
little about how to farm,
even if it's just
a pot of herbs.
You can get herbs in
almost any supermarket now.
That might be another
way to engage people
to understand,
oh, this is basil.
This is what this tastes like.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: Yeah.
Totally.
I mean it's interesting.
First of all, it's
really rewarding.
And I think most people see that
even with a small pot of herbs.
And it's very prolific too.
You can get so much food
from a single plant.
You can do so much
with relatively little.
And I think that's actually a
great wake-up call for people.
Like, oh wow.
The reason that-- when food
stamps started, one of the main
reasons that people got food
stamps was to get seeds.
Because it's wildly
less expensive to buy
a seed and then grow
the food yourself.
So I think people are
starting to wake up to that.
But also, there's
an amazing movement
of young people interested
in agriculture itself.
Young people farming, WWOOF'ing,
going around the world,
staying on farms
and volunteering.
And in America, people
interning at farms
and apprenticing at farms.
And it's not like kids that are
growing up just in farmland.
It's actually a lot of
kids who are growing up
in suburban America
who are like,
I have no idea where
my food comes from.
Maybe that's something
I should learn.
And so it's very cool to see
the whole spectrum of people
being interested in growing.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I think
that is inevitable.
If you start cooking and you
keep asking questions, it goes,
where does that come from?
And where does that come from?
And maybe at some point you
get to the health of the soil.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: Well,
which is also huge.
I mean, it's funny.
Because your original
point about how--
it's terrorism and some of
these even local security
issues of inner city
security issues--
all those things
seem much more sexy.
But what's really sexy
is actually the soil.
And when you look at a
big massive cornfield
where most of our corn-based
ingredients come from,
it is dead soil with
nothing growing in it.
And just like a sprout
of crop coming up
out of it miraculously.
And that I think is a
really great education
for people to see.
That's not really how
stuff is supposed to grow.
And I think more and more, both
in our domestic food systems
and also in our understanding
of international food systems,
we've realized we
don't invest in soil.
And we keep the
runoff going and we
keep the chemicals pouring on.
That is not the answer to
long-term food security.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And there is
investigation and connecting
our gut biome with
the biome in the soil.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: Exactly.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And we're
really connected to the Earth.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: It's
amazing even last year,
how much I've seen about
the probiotic, prebiotic.
It's all of that,
but it's funny,
because it's great marketing
for a lot of companies.
It's just like eat
healthy, real food.
And you've got it.
You know what I mean?
But it is funny how we as
consumers are like, wait!
It's like high fiber, no
GMO, prebiotic something.
OK.
I'll buy it.
Well maybe it's just like
yogurt with fruit in it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Good point.
Good point.
AUDIENCE: How do you foresee us
balancing the educating adults
who might have children versus
educating children directly.
I remember people-- when I
had economics in high school--
but people always
said they should
have personal finance should
actually be the class.
Who cares about economics,
what happens to your wallet.
We had Home Ec in school, but
we never had food education.
Where's that come into play?
Just teaching adults
and hoping they
teach their children versus
just teaching the kids.
FEMALE SPEAKER: You had Home Ec?
ELLEN GUSTAFSON:
I had Home Ec too.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Wow.
I thought that was
dead in the water.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: No.
Most of what we did
was try to figure out
how to get pasta to
stick to the ceiling.
Seriously, that's
definitely what we did.
And it does work.
It's the right al
dente consistency.
But no.
I mean, it's interesting.
Cause there's people that are
so focused on kids, kids, kids,
and then going home.
But then what's sad is if
you're focusing on giving kids
healthier food in school,
but they won't eat it
because nothing that
they're eating at home
reflects any of the stuff that's
the healthier school meal.
It's very hard.
They're going to
reject it and then
it's going to look
like a failure.
But the flip side is if parents
are at home banging their head
against the wall to get
their kids to eat healthier,
but then every week in
their kid's classroom
is a cupcake party for
someone's birthday,
I mean, it's really
a push pull, right?
But I think what has to
happen, and what did happen,
and what has happened in every
single major culture shift
is things kind of go
in a demographic wave.
And so I don't foresee that
young parents of my-- not every
single young parent in
my generation-- yes,
some people still
will take their kids
regulatory to McDonald's
because they have to.
Or because it's really the
much more convenient option.
I don't see most young parents
regularly taking their kids
to fast food.
Where as I grew up
going to fast food
not because my mom wasn't
educated about food and health,
because she didn't realize.
I think that's
where demographics
are very interesting.
The mom who starts her child
on organic milk and she
gets it at Wal-Mart.
It's the only thing she can
do, but she's read all about it
and she wants to
do the right thing.
I don't think that mom
is going to go back.
And in the recession,
that mom didn't go back.
So I kind of see
the demographics
moving and shifting
as we get older
and as we are continuing to be
the more powerful consumers,
and then our kids grow up behind
that, I actually see the wave
totally going in
the right direction.
Whereas you know, we who grew
up in the '80s, the wave kind of
went in the wrong
direction for awhile.
And of course, all
different age groups
are getting interested in
food in a different way.
I've seen some cool
entrepreneurial projects
where retirement
communities are being
built around a central farm
instead of a central golf
course.
Which is much better use
of the land, by the way.
And golf is kind
of boring to me.
But I think that's kind
of a cool response,
that people are
realizing that maybe--
and actually there's all these
great data about as people age
and if they garden as they age,
they age better and healthier.
So I think there's
an interesting move
along the entire
spectrum of people,
but really there's
a demographic wave
that-- there's going to be a
generation of kids who doesn't
grow up assuming that the
Happy Meal is the best
thing in the world.
And that's I think, where the
change will eventually come.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I
think in the same way
that television commercials are
pointed at kids to get parents
to buy sugared cereal,
if we know the same truth
and we feed the
kids cereal-- I mean
if we feed the kids
quinoa, the kid might
go home and ask for quinoa.
And ideally, the young
parent will go, oh,
I'll learn how to make quinoa.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: Right.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And I
think that's happening.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: Yeah.
I really do.
I really do think
that's happening.
This is where I get frustrated.
A lot of people point to
an elitist element of food.
And it's just not true.
I mean it really--
it's not true.
There are barriers right now,
because the other system,
the system that is, the
structure of our current food
system is highly subsidized.
And that makes it harder for the
mom doesn't have as much money
to just throw her
hands up and say, OK.
Look, let's just go and
get the expedient thing.
But the fact that
Wal-Mart is continuing
to expand its organic
options is showing
that every single group
of people of eaters,
especially in our country,
is learning about this.
People are not dumb.
They might not have as
much financial resources,
but they're not asleep to
the changes that probably
need to happen for them
and their family's diet.
And I think that's also
really important to remember,
that it's so easy
to just say, well,
poor people can't
afford organic food.
But poor people couldn't
afford cellphones either,
until cellphones
were made in a way
that the system
made it so everybody
could get a cell phone.
And food has to follow that.
The entrepreneurs
have to come in,
the systems have to be
built, the food options
have to be available.
And then everybody
can afford it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Wonderful.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: And the
policies have to change.
Can't forget that.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Oh that.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Any other?
AUDIENCE: What do you see
as the most promising policy
directions for making
the good options?
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: You know
what what's been interesting
is what's now kind of in debate,
but I think the-- especially
at the USDA, there was a great
leader, Kathleen Merrigan, who
was there, and was really
kind of a voice for the more
sustainable food women.
And the fact that she was
even picked to be at the USDA
in a senior position
was pretty interesting.
Because that's a
pretty radical shift
away from a former Monsanto
executive, which everybody else
around her probably was.
But I think what people have
seen through the first lady's
leadership and the
school food shifts
is actually much bigger
than just school food.
The buying power
and the legislation
around how school food
is purchased really
has set the tone for a lot of
the rest of our food system.
So an example of
that is that we used
to have rules that a school
district couldn't preference
a local or regional source
for their food supply.
And those rules changed
in the last few years.
So now they can preference
a local or regional source.
Which I mean, is such
a no-brainer, right?
But that big food
service would now say,
oh, I can look to
my local community
and say what are
the farmers growing?
Can I buy that instead of just
whatever the commodity product
is for the DOD fresh offering?
So at that level,
the policy changes
to help schools
get healthier food
first of all into
their cafeterias
and then eventually to the
kids, is a pretty big change.
I mean it's not
anywhere near the change
that we need in
school food, but I
think that's a
really interesting--
and it seems like there
are still of course now,
people are debating this.
And saying, oh parents
should have the choice.
The choice argument
is so ridiculous,
because there's no
choice whether subsidies.
It's a completely false
choice because everyone
is very influenced by the
pricing differentials.
But I do think that the fact
that some movement in school
food has been able
to be successful
is a very big indication
that people are recognizing
that these changes
are going to happen.
And they need to happen.
FEMALE SPEAKER: What's the one
thing that could trip us up?
You're saying this
wave is happening,
the demographics are right,
but what's our vulnerability?
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: I think
our big vulnerability
is just how in deep we've
gotten with monocultures
of very few crops.
Corn, soy, wheat, cotton.
Kind of sums it up.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And
one variety of each.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: Yes.
Exactly.
At leasf of soy and corn.
The GMO version of those crops.
The power that that
one variety of one crop
now has in our food
system is just insane.
But what's interesting, I
frame the ethanol debate
in terms of answering
this question
that we've been so
good at growing corn.
Farmers were told, grow
corn fence row to fence row.
And they did it.
Which by the way, means that if
you tell them something else,
they can do that too.
American farmers
are really smart,
entrepreneurial,
hardworking people.
Whatever we the eaters ask
them to grow, they'll grow.
But what they've been asked
to grow is tons of corn.
And when corn has fallen out
of favor maybe in soft drinks,
or in people are eating
more grass-fed meat,
or whatever the shifts
are, we find uses for it,
instead of thinking
well maybe we
should just stop
growing so much corn.
We've put it in our cars.
We send it overseas more
and more to hungry kids
or to other markets.
And it's not just the
global marketplace at work,
it's subsidies at work,
and it's us finding ways
for these very few
crops because we're
so dependent on this system.
Instead of us saying, let's
just shift the system.
And that's I think
the biggest fear,
is that there won't
ever be enough
political will to
fight the entrenched
power of that system,
and get farmers to really
have the ability to shift
what they're growing,
and make real money and a
living growing other things that
are healthier.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So mono
cropping and growing
on unbelievable scales.
Just huge.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: Huge.
I mean, and just these few
crops that are literally
dominating our diet and the
global diet in such a big way.
And the power that that
brings to those companies.
So that's why part
of my argument
is that disempowering those
few stakeholders by not buying
those crops is a way to shift
the balance of power, at least.
It's very small at first,
but it has to happen,
because if we don't
pull money out
of those industries,
the industries who
are going to have
the most money,
they're going to be the
largest force in Washington.
AUDIENCE: I've got a question.
So I'm surprised that you
said our food choices aren't
the problem.
The reason we grow so much corn
and soy is to feed the animals.
And that with meat requiring
20 times as much protein
from plants to make protein
for meat, with that 20 to 1
multiplier effect,
I don't see how,
unless we change our eating
habits to shift away from meat,
we can have a sustainable--
enough to feed the whole world.
I think even if we
ate what Americans
think of as a healthy diet, the
world couldn't eat that way.
There's not enough land.
Even is it's grass-fed, and
that takes even more land.
So I think that there really
are some fundamental issues
with a meat-based diet
that have to be looked at.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: I don't
argue that at all, actually.
What I argue is that
choice is not the issue.
Because American
consumers are being
told that you can
have the choice
to buy a $0.99 hamburger.
When we agree-- I'm sure--
that that's not realistic.
A hamburger doesn't
actually cost $0.99.
It can't.
If you actually added
in the real cost
of growing all that corn,
the real cost of all
the petrochemicals
that are involved,
the real cost of
the drugs it takes
to keep the animals alive, the
real cost of the transportation
to get the animal back and forth
to all the different places
it goes before it
gets to your plate.
That's not built into the cost,
therefore it's a false choice.
It's letting people think that
we can eat meat at this level
from an economic
perspective, and we can't.
You're exactly right.
We can't eat the amount
of meat that we eat
and the way we eat it without
high levels of subsidies going
into these products from
so many different places.
And so what I'm arguing is
that if the consumer saw
the real price of
that meat, we actually
couldn't afford to
eat it every day.
And therefore, we
would eat less of it,
and we'd eat better quality.
And therefore,
the rest the world
wouldn't be sold down the
river that you can produce meat
in this way, and all these
hamburgers just overflowing
from McDonald's
every single day.
Or whatever other
places there are.
I think I'm looking at
it from the perspective
that if we the
consumer, we the eater,
knew really what the
cost of that burger was,
we couldn't choose to
have it as often as we do.
And then our eating habits, of
course, would have to change,
and would change.
Because that would mean
that our diets would reflect
more of what makes rational
sense from what we can grow
and what we can afford.
So yeah, it's sad
that we're coming
to this place from
a health perspective
now after we've sold China, and
Brazil, and India, and Africa,
and all these other
population rich places
with our diet and our systems.
Now all the sudden we're
coming to this realization
that, oh wait.
Maybe this diet and the
system doesn't work very well.
And so if you look at
the data, Americans
are actually eating less meat.
But I mean, right.
It's not a dramatic change.
But it's a downward slope.
And it's a shame that we've
been pushing the upward slope
to everybody else before
we kind of realized this.
But I do think that
if we radically
change-- if Americans
wake up to these issues
and really change
the type of meat
that we eat, the quantities
in which we eat it,
we don't waste it, we change
the way our meat is produced,
and we have a little bit more
concern for the environmental,
and also the humanitarian
and animal welfare elements
of the way we've been producing
meat, that has the ability
to radically change the
way we Americans eat meat.
The hope is can that
then be reflected
in the global marketplace
and how the rest of the world
eats meat also.
Just pulling our money, and
we are pulling our money away
from that system, by not
buying corn-based products
in the same way, by not
buying-- buying soda helps feed
into that system.
I mean it's so interconnected.
Buying high fructose
corn syrup Concorde jelly
instead of a real jam
feeds into that system.
So it's amazing
how interconnected
and how expansive it is.
But I would say that if
we look at the system
and we say, where can I remove
my lobbying dollars from that
system-- the powers
that be, that I think
is the way that the
consumer can help break
the stranglehold on
Washington and on policies
that these very
few interests have.
And so I would argue that you
get people from the health,
from the personal,
from the community,
from the "my jeans don't fit,"
and then you can bring them
to-- oh, the reason
for all of this.
The reason we've gone so far
off the rails, the reason
that we now have this raging
obesity crisis that literally
didn't exist before, is
because of this system.
And here's the system.
And here's the players.
And here's how we change it.
And call your congressperson.
One thing I've
been frustrated by,
especially working
on global aid issues,
is you've got a lot of people
that really mean well and care
about helping to
feed the hungry,
but then I would argue eat
in a way that perpetuates
the systems that
keep people hungry.
A great example
of that is eating
the typical cheap bananas
and coffee and sugar
that we all eat every
day really hurts
some of the largest
populations of hungry people
that are right to our
south that then end up
becoming immigrants.
Honduras and Guatemala are
places that grow our food.
We want them to
grow our food cheap.
We don't want to pay them
real prices for that food.
We get pissed that
they or their kids
are coming in and
immigrating here.
And then we go to Washington
to bitch about the immigration,
instead of saying,
let's actually
look at this whole system
here and realize that,
maybe if we actually paid a
fair price for all the hard work
that these people are
doing to grow our food,
and a realistic system is set
up where people can actually
be compensated for all of
this incredible variety
that we have in
our supermarkets,
maybe then we wouldn't have the
downstream political effects.
And I think that's
the same thing
we need to come to with the big
picture food policy issues too.
Until people realize that
there are only four major meat
companies.
One dairy company controls
40% of the dairy market,
including a huge chunk
of the organic market.
Until people realize
that, we're not
going to get them to
understand what that means
when they call their
congressperson.
So I'm certainly
arguing that we've
got to get the dollars to shift.
And I know that there are
also amazing organizations
and people that
are totally focused
on the high-level
political shifts too.
But we have to pull
the dollars out.
We can't just say, hey,
Congressperson change,
until we pull the dollars out.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Thank you so much.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
For being with us.
ELLEN GUSTAFSON:
Thanks for having me.